It's the the space to produce food and to supply them.
All rich.
Performers limited resources for survival and yet we are increasing our
population is important because.
Demand is at the root of our most critical environmental process.
On this map.
Population growth will be recorded from year one to the budget and then
projected that it would hit a 20 point population in total.
That location of the could five dollars each of which represents one million
people
is going to reference points are provided by the images on the right.
Japan.
He turned this down.
Well I think you got the message
that I was actually going to show you.
This is the end of the course.
To show you the beginning of the course a little video but it was not.
Not in the right format.
And it shows our favorite dung beetles copulating.
And.
It's very it's very graphic.
And it looks just like humans with the same rhythm everything same motions.
So and the message of the course was this is what this course has been about.
Start with insects doing their thing and end up with humans doing their thing.
And in between nothing really has changed the desire to engage in sex has not
changed the quest for status to determine sex.
I mean we we've had this over and over again in the chorus and I hope you
realized by now that we've discussed so much from the Princeton Project and
other projects how much social acceptance is an important part of fertility that
people determine their own fertility a lot because of what is the acceptable
norm in the community.
And aside from the direct status of having a lot of sons and a big family gives
you big status because of protection and political power from a large family and
economic security.
But it's all tied in with status.
Well I think I mentioned to you that for instance in Bangladesh they looked at
fertility as a function of religiosity.
And one factor that had some effect was the religiosity of the particular
family.
But the much bigger effect was the religiosity of the community.
It's all community acceptance it's all status.
And we just.
That comes directly from the chimpanzees.
And of course you aware that a vast percentage of human consumption spend and
more.
The richer you get the more of it is is status consumption in the Mercedes and
the Ford is basically status in that kind of thing
so you've also seen that between groups the hostility between groups has not
basically not changed since.
A simple chimpanzees.
The.
The maltreatment of females the battering of females among chimpanzees the
battering of females among humans.
It's all stayed about the same.
So if I could have shown you that that video you'd have gotten the message that
why did it.
Also why this is a biology course or at least part of the reason is because the
fundamentals of almost everything that we've talked about on the same set of
behavioral propensities that are apparently wired into us in some way since our
chimpanzee days.
OK so this last this video that you did see.
The main point is that the situation we are in now with respect to population is
totally unprecedented in the history of humanity.
There's just never been anything like it.
And you also know something about the future.
Will come.
Oh that might help to put it.
Here we go.
But
that video was made in.
I wrote that and I think 1990 and the projections the the actual numbers are
pretty good for their projection.
Oh this is not.
None of it and I'll show you the situation.
OK good.
Why is this the there
Kohei
No it should work.
OK so.
What's usually these are the projections that the U.N.
has put up for the future of population.
So I think I showed you the early in the course when I was discussing
quantitative methods the US Census Bureau projection and that more or less
mimics this one.
But the UN shows you that there's a range they do not know what's going to
happen.
And so they give you a range of possibilities for the future and they do not
call them predictions at all.
They are simply projections meaning that if X Y Z or Q happens then this will be
the course of population but they don't say which of these things is going to
happen if any of them.
So what would you consider in terms of say fertility what would you consider the
most conservative projection.
We know what's happened in the past.
We know what the status is today what you're how shall we make our future
projection.
Fertility staying the same fertility going up fertility going down.
Things down.
OK.
So the U.N.
That's one of the projections.
To my mind the most conservative projection is that whatever we're at today
that's what we we continue to be at.
It's in the sense that's what I think conservative means that you preserve
what's been in the past.
Well that's this projection that the fertility that the world is at today
continues just just as it is.
And the projections carried out to 2050 and assuming that we are where we are it
will be population will be 12 billion.
We're now about six point seven billion.
Population will be not quite double what we are now and rising ever faster.
So that's that's the status quo assumption.
The other assumptions are optimistic that things will that fertility will come
down and they're not unreasonable assumptions and the reason why some of you
chose fertility coming in because fertility has been coming down so it's not a
it's not a crazy presumption but how much is it going to come down.
So the U.N.
gives you three possibilities.
So.
This projection
which they called the high projection assumes that fertility will come down
another half of a child right now.
This was based on the average fertility between 2000 2005 who's got 2.8 children
2.8 five children.
And they're presuming in this projection that it'll come down another half a
child for every.
The average for everyone on earth to two point three five still above
replacement level fertility with that degree of optimism that comes out another
half a child population keeps increasing not as fast as this.
And by 2050 we get to roughly 11 billion.
And it's pretty much going up.
In a straight line.
Now you can get a little bit more optimistic and say well it's going to come
down a whole child's worth.
And that's this
scenario here now or at one point eight five.
The whole world has come down to a quarter of the replacement of all fertility
as you know is two point one children.
So one point eighty five is a quarter child below replacement fertility.
And you can decide for yourself how much optimism is involved in assuming that's
going to happen.
But if that's the case then population is like 9 billion in 2050 and continuing
up but clearly beginning to level off at that time.
Now they get really optimistic and they do this
this line.
And that's it drops a child and a half.
In this short amount of time.
And that goes down to one point three five children per woman way below
replacement fertility and that's for the whole world.
The assumptions are the.
What is going on
sorry about this I don't know what's problematic here today.
So these are the the UN's own statement of its of its assumptions the constant
fertility one footnote remains constant at that average of more or less two
point eighty two point eighty five.
The high fertility assumption they're calling a reduction from now high.
The high fertility.
Two point three five children medium one point eight five one point three five.
And then they have a really miraculous something the instant replacement
assumption which they don't bother to graph which is each country immediately
like tomorrow comes down to just the birth rate that will replace its population
no more no less.
So what what should we notice about these things.
Obviously they're pretty arbitrary assumptions.
No one knows what's going to happen in the future.
No one claims to know what's going to happen in the future.
And it's a sign that
you know we don't we just don't know enough about this issue.
I mean I've told you a lot of what's the basic stuff that's known but we have we
do not know enough to really predict you.
We asked at the beginning in the course the middle of the end of the course and
why has fertility been coming down.
What are the determinants of fertility.
And you've gotten a whole lot of answers.
If we knew the answer for sure we would be able to predict.
But the future is not terribly predictable.
OK.
So these are projections not not predictions.
They've got a huge range there.
From about 8 billion to about 12 billion.
That's an uncertainty not terribly distant future 50 percent.
That's a very very large degree of uncertainty.
Only the most optimistic assumption this last one.
Only the most optimistic projection has population decreasing by 2050.
All the other assumptions show it continuing to increase right through 2050 with
no no statement about what might or might not happen beyond that
so in the medium Variant This is the one that they call the Medium Variant.
And because they use that word medium the press sort of takes this as well the
most likely something you and does not say anything about the likelihood of any
of these estimates.
But take your choice
in this rise that we're now increasing it like 70 19 2000 up to 2007 the average
rise was about 78 million a year.
In this scenario by 2050 its population is still increasing by 30 million a
year.
So that's their Medium Variant as far out as they're willing to even project not
predict but even to project population still increasing by 30 million a year.
I keep saying these are optimistic.
Remember none of these assume that fertility starts rising again.
We haven't had a fall in fertility.
And there are certainly reasons to believe that if the world that we've had a
fall in fertility and we've also had really rather great progress in the world
say since the end of World War 2 I mean people are staying alive they're getting
more educated or parts of the world China India Indonesia are just unbelievably
richer than than they used to be although still very poor and pockets of real
poverty exist.
I mean most of the world has just improved tremendously both in the rich
countries the West Japan and in the poor countries.
If you had to choose a date that you would like to be alive but you couldn't
choose who you would be or where you would be the only reasonable date to choose
is now because because the average human being on earth was worse worse worse go
going back as far as you want.
Now if you could choose to be a rich person that's maybe another story but if
you if you just would be randomly seated anywhere you choose to be now.
So things have been getting better.
There's no question about it.
If things continue to get better we it's very reasonable presume that one of
these maybe not this curb but one of these more optimistic curves might take
place.
But there are a lot of reasons why things may not continue to get better and in
the paper that segments of a paper that I wrote I list a number of them.
One that I listed was economic collapse and I was talking about the fairly small
economic collapse in Asia in 1997 which had happened at about that time.
And I did not envision as did no one.
You know this.
We have really no global kind of a mega crash.
And will we recover or not.
Who knows.
But if economic progress is one of the things that's required or economic
increase is one of the things that's required for population to keep coming down
then the global economy.
Who knows what's going to happen.
It may very well turn around.
Religious fundamentalism is is another thing that we know that it's not a
particular religion Christianity or Islam or or or Judaism that matters but it
is the religiosity the degree to which people are religious in whatever their
religious tradition is.
That latter makes a difference.
And religious fundamentalism is basically increasing all across the world
including the United States because I read an article that Notre Dame is one of
the great Catholic universities in America.
And the priests a number of the priests that of the order that founded Notre
Dame and still run it didn't want the President Obama was invited to be
the speaker at graduation this year.
And the priests didn't want him to be because he's pro-abortion.
So the conservatism in at one end of the spectrum of all religions is is there
and increasing.
You see the Taliban which at one end of the Islamic spectrum they are powerful
now increasingly powerful not only in Afghanistan but now in Pakistan.
And I know you've been reading the newspapers but there they have now taken a
provincial big city or capital.
It's like 13 and 30 miles or something from Islamabad the capital of Pakistan.
So they're they're increasing the population of Orthodox Jews in Israel because
they reproduce so much faster than everyone else is is very close to overtaking
the population of more moderate Jews and the Palestinians and the Orthodox Jews
in Israel are having a battle to see who can increase their their fertility fast
enough to sort of out reproduce the other and et cetera.
Another factor is the decline in support for international family planning
programs as you're undoubtedly where the population explosion which was very hot
issue for the press and for all kinds of activists organizations in the 1960s
and 1970s has just fallen off the map.
Our own school of environmental studies here forestry does not have a single
person that pays any attention to human population courses like this are taught
basically nowhere else and very few places elsewhere.
Environmental organizations won't go near the population issue.
And so governments not under any pressure from the citizens are reducing their
support of family planning.
And this has already happened in large degree as well as a lot of other good
good programs.
And with the economic problems of all governments now it's going to be even
further
not economic
exacerbate social problems
Vega said.
So do do economic problems exacerbate social problems so that people will want
to more control their fertility government.
So what you say is really but the opposite of everything that we've sort of said
in the course that's when things are getting better that when when people come
from being except for land availability that when when infant mortality goes
down people reduce their birthrate when education is available people reduce
their birthrate when countries get richer people reduce their birthrate.
So no it's exactly the opposite of that.
You should take definitely take that away from from this call that good things
happen when things are already getting getting better and the reduction in
fertility.
Goes along with.
I didn't say cause but goes along with an improvement in every kind of condition
that that you can count and when the economy goes by I mean and then in the 1997
Asian crisis a lot of women working the cities and not having at factories and
sewing and so were not having children.
They lost their jobs and went back to the villages and guess what they did and
they started having children.
So it's improvement in the situation that that gets fertility down
because.
OK excellent.
So what her question was because this is a short term more of an economic shock
than a depression.
Maybe people will temporarily reduce their fertility.
And that's.
That's a wonderful
observation.
And economists really don't know how to answer that.
So when I when I started teaching this course I taught the CO taught it with the
professor of economics and he was teaching sort of the economic determinism this
is really what he believed and he thought that as countries come up economically
fertility will come down.
More or less automatically.
And he was of the mind that development is the best contraceptive I've shown
you.
Since then the data has shown I think clearly shown that's not not the case.
But that was his belief then.
Then comes this 1997 economic collapse in Asia.
And I go up to this professor who I was not teaching with anymore.
He says I say to him hey gee here's this economic collapse in Asia.
What do you think will happen.
And he said to me I think fertility will go down which is what you're saying
because conditions are getting worse.
And what you're saying and I was shocked and I said but I won't say his name.
But that's exactly the opposite of what you're taught in the course.
And what he said to me was I think the theory is flexible enough to accommodate
both results which means the theory didn't predict anything.
If you can predict this and then the opposite.
It doesn't predict anything.
So we don't know the answer to this.
I mean first of all we don't know if this is a temporary economic collapse.
Mean we hope it is but no guarantees.
And the the the data to figure out the inventory what's short term which is
undefined and what's long term which is undefined very difficult to do.
You may be right.
You may be wrong.
I think we just can't be certain about that
and of course the other factor which could cause things to go to hell in a
handbasket
is environmental collapse that if the environment gets bad things start getting
used up.
If people really start starving or losing not having water or whatever the
environment will do first and we'll talk maybe a little bit about what might
happen first.
Then again things could go backwards very very fast.
So
none of this is our predictions that I'm saying.
I'm just saying that here's all this optimism.
All of these except the top the constant among all of those are optimistic
presumptions that may take place.
But there's just as many reasons to think that no things will turn around and
fertility will go back up and we just don't know
the future
but what we we can't say that by all is any kind of reasonable assumption for
the next 40 years at least we're in for a very significant increase in
population that is going to happen.
So how does how does one concept I am trying to make this lecture at least
somewhat about the environment.
How does one relate this population increase to environment to environmental
destruction to decay of the environment.
This is not an easy question.
There are so many variables between human population and and environmental
destruction that it's hard to pick out what's just
due to due to the population.
And the simplest statement that you can make is that the total human
environmental footprint footprint is and is an idea come up by I get some invite
I don't know is there a name attached to who came up with the use of the word
footprint.
Anyway the idea of the total environmental impact impact of an individual city a
country an industry whatever the environmental footprint is what's said and in
the simplest way of thinking about it the environmental footprint is
proportional the number of people each people on earth have an average
footprint.
The more people the bigger the footprint and that holds it any any level any
assumptions you want to put on it more people bigger footprint.
So that's that's fairly obvious
but it's not doesn't tell you an awful lot.
And so many years ago a guy named John Holdren proposed on sort of a expansion
of that idea and he is now Obama's the director of the Office of Science and
Technology just recently appointed by President Obama.
So at least you have now have someone in power who thinks about population and
what he came up with as was this equation the impact the environmental impact.
He breaks it down and says you don't have to worry only about population but how
rich is that population.
That's the difference when rich people and poor people.
What about the technology involved.
So.
Affluence is that we clearly know that rich people consume a lot more than poor
people between the poorest groups on Earth and the riches are a factor of
something like 40 depending on how poor you want to go and how rich you want to
go that number can be almost anything but 40 is a reasonable number to keep in
mind.
So affluence is certainly important.
The amount of money your population has and technology.
So nowadays if we want to knock down a forest we use bulldozers and chain saws
you know chain saws that'll cut down a 40 foot tree with one swipe and clearly
that technology allows you to have a much greater impact than if you're going
out there with a little hand hatchet or maybe even a stone axe to try to chop
down your tree.
The amount of technology that one has
clearly makes a tremendous difference in how much destruction you can do
what you should notice is that like all so this is symbolized by IPART.
The impact as population affluence technology or multiply together you should
keep in mind that this is a tautology tautology means something which is always
true.
The equation is always true and you just see that.
You define population just people.
Affluence is the income per person number of dollars that person has.
And technology is defined in this nice way of the impact per dollar spent right.
So that's the how you're defining these terms how you're measuring these terms
and you'll just notice that if you if you cross multiply the persons and persons
cancel out the dollars and dollars cancel out your equation ends up that the
impact is equal to the impact.
So that's a sign of a true equation true here.
No no.
It's a tautology it's always always the case.
And I should show you that for instance this is standard thing out of Science
magazine one of their stories about population and what are they doing impact.
Here's the first thing that last impact per dollar so that in this case the
impact there is carbon budget.
So they're talking about the carbon budget.
They even use the word budget for that and it's for each U.S. dollar.
This is a global figure they're going to give you but they're calculating it in
U.S. dollars for each each dollar spent on something in the world.
How much carbon is used.
And so that's kilograms of carbon per dollar and it's about now about a quarter.
And it's changed somewhat over time but not enormously.
So it's gotten better.
This is this is the lower the number the better that for each dollar of stuff
that you buy there's basically less carbon used to make it so that.
So this kind of way of thinking about environmental impacts is now actually
rather standard and you really can't avoid this kind of thinking.
One of the real important things about this that people make mistakes on all the
time is that the factors multiply that you don't add the population plus the
affluence plus the technology you multiply them.
And one of the there's a very important book so I think it's called not
something new under the sun.
And the guy who wrote it
Yale tried to hire him as our environmental historian and he was adding these
factors and making all kinds of totally wrong conclusions and saying that well
the rate of growth of affluence is so much and the rate of growth of population
is so much.
So this one is more important than that one just saying utter nonsense because
he didn't realize the importance of the fact that there was ever anything per
capita is multiplied by the total population.
To get your global impact in the global impact is something you're interested in
the total impact the total amount of carbon dioxide not increased so much how
much carbon actually I put into the air but how much the 6 7 billion of us put
into the air
OK.
Now the equation looks simple and it's always true and.
And yet it's not as straightforward as as one would like because people take
something beyond the total logical fact of it being true with this as I've
describe it what this makes you think it's well an increase in population is
always bad it always increases the impact an increase in affluence is always bad
it always increases the impact and improvement in technology is always bad.
It increases the impact that's not not true that as people get richer as
affluence goes up they tend to spend a somewhat larger fraction of their income
on environmental issues that once you have a nice house and life nice car nice
school nice clothing you may actually want to breathe nice nice air and look at
something green and have a park to go walk into.
So rich people do indeed spend more than poor people on environmental issues.
So affluence can work both ways.
And that's very important to remember.
However you have to step back a little bit and say well in the world what
fraction of our increasing affluence have we actually spent on the environment
and the increase.
We've spent a very small fraction of it.
So in fact the overwhelming dominant effect of our affluence has indeed been to
have a greater impact on the environment.
And we've ameliorate that a little bit.
I mean very noticeable the rivers in America rich place rivers or really a lot
of rivers have been cleaned up.
A lot of smog has been cleaned up.
So we have made progress in certain very visible ways.
We've exported a fair amount of our environmental concerns to other parts of the
world by having them manufacture stuff and bringing it in here and bringing
knocking down their forests to bring in wood and so forth and the Chinese and
the Japanese have done just the same kind of thing.
Similarly with technology it doesn't always work one way that yes technology
allows you to blow off a mountain top to get some coal.
You know you've seen these these horrific pictures of West Virginia and so forth
where a beauty you know more or less beautiful mountain that's covered in trees
and look you're just gone and all that mount up becomes slagging pollutes rivers
and acidifying rivers and does horrible things.
You have this ugly scarred up land.
So technology does that but also improvement of technology brings with the
mining of copper.
So when you replace copper wires with fiber optics they're made of glass and
glass is made from sand and the harvesting of sand doesn't do an awful lot of
environmental destruction so that's an improvement in the environment.
And there's a number of examples
of that.
And again you have to ask how cars are current push now to make cars that use
less gas so that the good that it does use it gets you how many to drive a mile
you use less gas not enormously less but but somewhat less so technology can
help you.
And again the standard questions.
Has our improvement technology over the last 20 30 40 50 years whatever time
window you want or deal with has this allowed us to do more environmental
destruction of of the earth or have we used enough a biggest a big enough
fraction of it to improve the environment ah ah ah efficiency of use of the
environment that the things have gotten better.
And the answer is there's no question about what's happened
because you see in this again this is more CO2 stuff that here is the sources of
CO2 addition into the air which is a very good index of what's happening the
total economy and what you see is the land the land use so land adds into the
CO2 by
where know deforestation and using wood for timber and everything.
So the amount the land use the changes in land use has not enormously changed
the width of that line is more or less the same over time.
So the change in land use is putting about the same amount of carbon into the
air as before.
There's a little bit of other emissions which we don't have to worry about but
fossil fuel combustion has just gone up up up up.
So whatever the balance of our affluence and our technology whatever the balance
but we can see that as the balance of our use between using it to ameliorate the
environment versus messing up the environment OK we'll come back to the slide if
we have a chance.
The.
In terms of the efficiency that first factor the well not the first factor the
the dollars per carbon use that is here actually the carbon use per dollar is
quite interesting that it has been coming down from 1970 it was about a third of
a kilogram of carbon per dollar and that's come down to now something like a
quarter.
Of a kilogram per dollar spent.
And that's just carbon.
So you multiply that likes by almost 4 2.
If you want to measure in CO2 because carbon is about one quarter of each CO2
molecule.
So it's basically we know for each dollar spent we
put out two pounds a kilogram of carbon.
So every time you go and buy something just you give them a dollar and say
that's two pounds of carbon coming into carbon dioxide I'm putting into the
atmosphere it's it's a not crazy way of thinking about things.
So what is worrying people now is that this has been a pretty good decline but
actually this is now turning out to be more significant than people thought the
rate of decline here.
That's declining efficiency of use of carbon was about one point three percent a
year.
It's no longer declining and this seems to have have continued.
It's now going up by three point three percent three tenths of a percent a year.
So it looks like the that we've we've picked the easy apples the easy the low
hanging fruit as they say in improving our carbon efficiency and now we may be
getting worse again
OK.
So all of that is about how to think.
Well now one of the one of the ways of putting in a quantitative view of the
relationship between population and the environmental impact.
So there's many many other considerations the relationship between population
and impact.
One is the expansion of humans into almost every habitat on Earth.
There's almost no no limit to this.
So I'll show you some limiting some extreme cases of this.
Now what's going on it's something that Malta's talked about.
Remember we described what Malta said living in England just about eighteen
hundred and.
The population was increasing.
And what did they do.
So they were farmland the best farmland was already farmed.
But as there were more farmers the farmers had to move on to more marginal land
less good land.
And what he was thinking was that there's a law of diminishing returns that you
have farmers on good land they're producing so much performer and it's fairly
good England was not a very poor place as population increases.
They have to move on to drier land swap your land Hillier land and the the
production per farmer for these new farmers is less than those that had the best
land.
So while the total production grows.
And remember Malta showed a linear rise in total production.
Now with new people total production grows but population is growing like this
since each new person produces less than an old person.
He has to farm on worst land then that then the earlier farmers the average
productivity goes down.
And that is the thing that has happened all through history that of course
humans when they have a choice of land when there's not crowd or when nobody
else's is standing around they choose the best land the easiest to get along
with to get to survive in.
But then what happens is people move out into less good land.
The pictures I'm going to show you are from Niger which is in SA hell just south
of the Sahara Desert it actually sticks up into this horrid desert.
And this is a province of Niger called Isaac and it's a huge province because
there's not many people there.
It's a big thing right on the edge of the Sahara.
The population is fifty thousand people.
And in the dry season they have two wells in the hole for that whole huge
territory for that hole.
All those 50000 people there are only two wells and only one of them works works
regularly during the rainy season.
Think this and this is what it looks like in that country.
They have you can see there's there's there's no no no water nothing nothing
would grow on the ground.
Some of the trees that can survive grass doesn't survive this it's too small and
when it loses water it's gone.
Trees can store water basically and survive fairly long periods of drought to
get some what's called scrub since scrub forest in the wet season.
They're very joyous.
They have lots of water
they think lots of water.
But this is the amount of water that they have and the people use it for all
their their functions.
The animals I know you can see an animal back here.
The animals use it to drink and relieve themselves and here's girls washing in
this water.
And this this is in the good time of the year.
This is this is the water that they have to survive on
the dry season is nine months long.
You have some rain not a lot but some rain for three months.
Then the dry season is nine months long and then late this is the labor value of
children.
These young girls must travel 35 miles to one of the two wells that are
available.
That's the average depending on where they live that they go.
They have to walk.
No no mechanized transport.
They walk 35 miles and they can carry back only enough water.
So their families can drink one glass a day.
Remember we used to be told it's now shown to be not really scientific.
Drink eight glasses of water every day.
They're living on one ace one eighth of that amount of water
so you have to ask yourselves why do people live in such a God forsaken place.
You know this life is so hard and so miserable.
And what's the answer.
The better places have somebody in them.
Already.
So the story if you can do these sort of anthropological history is virtually
always that this time at one point lived in some much nicer place.
But some tribe got more populous got stronger in one way or another was more
vicious and they got pushed out of what was their original Aboriginal fairly
decent land onto more marginal land.
And so while they may have been living there now for hundreds of years in a
sense it's not their own choice to live on such a miserable part
of the world.
When you read and I think in the war before civilization I gave you some
readings in this book which calculated all the violence it described some people
some peoples that had been pushed out into these marginal lands by stronger
peoples it gives you a number of examples of that.
And of course the big example.
But big modern example is in America that the European settlers pushed the
American Indians the Native Americans into horrible lands.
The stories of pushing the Cherokees from nice farmland nice productive land and
say North Carolina and putting them to Oklahoma which is half drive or or the
Apaches various Indians pushed them off into the desert.
So you go see how miserably a lot of the the American Indians now live in the
Navajo reservations.
And so friends say Oh my God why do they want to live there.
And they didn't they didn't want to live there.
They weren't given a choice.
They were pushed pushed out
so it and we're talking about dryness which is one of the things that people
just happen we can't exist without water.
So this is really
the border of existence but where it's very wet you remember you read in
Bangladesh that people living on the mudflats and the monsoon come season comes
in the water rises or a flood comes and they're just washed out.
Those people didn't choose to live there.
There's no a land anywhere else.
So they they do whatever they can.
The Eskimos that live up on the polar ice cap there's some Eskimos that are
constant apparently constantly on the ice ice cap and don't have a base on land.
So when we think of people living in these very marginal circumstances one
attributes I mean this famines.
The people live in this region have famines every so often there's great drought
as you know right now parts of Africa have had terrible drought.
California has a terrible drought.
The Colorado River basin is having drought.
So when this happens it's always when then the people get into great trouble and
they can easily starve to death and some advanced country may or may not send
them food and sending them food has its own problems.
But it's always attributed to environmental variability to climatic troubles and
no one ever asked the question why have these been people been pushed into this
incredibly inhospitable region.
I mean part of the ecology of that region is you're going to have droughts every
so often and sometimes going to last for years and be very severe in
California's has the drought in California has now lasted for years.
So
everything in the environment the regime the population environment is circular
that people affect the environment then the environment comes and bites them
back if it comes back to them.
And water is one of the is one of the key things and probably what will give out
first when we really reach environmental limit.
It will almost certainly be fresh fresh water in a lot of information that you
can get on this very easily it's it's not secret at all.
There's two sources of water that humans can use which is freshwater you can
desalinate salt water but the energy costs are enormous.
So it's not unless you're an Arab sitting on an oil well you really can't do it
any reasonable way.
So this renewable water which is rainwater that when it rains that is renewable
there's a cycle of it goes up into the atmosphere and comes back down as rain.
So you have renewable water coming eventually into rivers and in one way or
another you tap the rivers and then there's mined water.
When you do mine it just like you mined coal you dig down and you suck up the
water and the greatest productivity of a lot of the the farm regions of the
world is comes from mined water.
So the big the Midwest of the U.S. especially as you get further west it is not
have enough rainfall.
So they use mined water and you probably have heard that the reason they can use
mined water is that underlying our Midwest is what's called the Ogallala Aquifer
Ogallala is a name of one of the Indian groups that used to live there the
Ogallala aquifer and the farmers all over the West they're just sink down a tube
and and suck up the water.
Well you have to think of you know being as scientists always want to know how
why where all this kind of stuff.
And since a kid you read about you know artesian wells and wells under water and
then eventually ask yourself how does water get into rock.
And the reason it that way is it drips in there.
And the Ogallala Aquifer actually filled from the melt off of the last ice age
prior to the peak of the last ice age was about eighteen thousand years ago.
And then it took about eight thousand years to melt till something like 10000
years ago.
It was very approximate numbers but for eight thousand years ice was melting the
water of the ground was soggy and drip drip drip.
Rock is never totally solid and is always somewhere some little crack in the
water slowly drips through the cracks and goes in in any kind of you know when
the rocks get folded there's there's caverns in there and any kind of space
eventually water will find its way.
Japan if you've ever paid attention to the roof on your house you know the water
gets in no matter what what you do.
So it's it's the filling of these aquifers is I don't know.
I can't when that ice age started but something and it took eight thousand years
to fill but that depended on a glacier which was there for the previous ten
thousand years.
So we're talking about a resource that is one of the shorter term resources and
it's something like it fills in thousand years.
Now we're sucking it up in decades and it's very much
going going way down.
And there were some slides that the reason I was a little late I could not find
the slides this morning I had them yesterday and I don't know where they went.
So I didn't put them on but they showed some interesting kinds of things that
when you're sitting on top of this aquifer you've got the rock and the water is
there Water's in compressed bowl so it holds up the rock you suck out the water.
There's now a space there.
And what happens the rock starts crumbling and falling down.
What happens is the land actually falls and the pictures that I that I could not
find show first from Houston Texas a farm there.
And it's shows you a pump just a concrete platform with a pump and you know
where the land was.
And then the land is several feet beneath that the land is just shrunken has
collapsed.
And the second picture I want to show is Galveston Texas not so far from
Houston.
Now the land has has fallen again all due to irrigation but they're near the
sea.
So the saltwater has come in and now what used to be good agricultural land is
now flooded with a Gulf of Mexico from that region.
You're shaking your head.
Maybe she knows but the most impressive picture comes from the San Joaquin
Valley of California.
Now you have problem that's where all our fruits and vegetables come from that's
that's the huge source of American food supply and probably almost all of you
today have already today eaten something that was farmed and locking anybody
from that part.
No.
Nobody nobody from.
We don't have to.
We don't have enough farmers at all.
Well this is a picture of a poll that they put in to measure the drop of the
land.
What you see is this very large poll and a man man is sort of down here and.
And what the poll is is the top of the polls where the land was in I can't here
like nineteen fifty seven or something like that.
And the land has dropped 30 feet in that time and the man is now you know five
and a half foot man or six foot man is a small fraction of this but it's really
a shocking kind of photo.
And of course the agricultural activity in the valleys of California has only
increased since then.
The amount of water pump has increased and the land keeps falling at a very
noticeable rate.
So it's very graphic
thing.
So now from when you suck out the water it takes quite a while for the for these
the rock to sort of collapse and fall down because it's got some structural
strength to it.
So if you can see that how much the land has fallen you can just imagine how
much the water table itself has held many times more than the actual land has
fallen.
And in some places you can measure this fairly readily.
So in parts of Texas and Arizona water tables have dropped hundreds of feet even
in northwest of Chicago.
There's been 200 to 300 foot drop in the water table just sucking it out three
quarters of Texas is irrigated area.
Water tables are falling.
And this is true all over the world.
I mean not states is very technological so we do a lot of drilling.
But the North China Plain which is again where the wheat in China is grown drops
40 inches every year.
Tamil Nadu in India southern India another very productive part of a 100 inches
a year.
The the the water tables are are falling.
The there's just just a study that that that just came out this in February
which measures the groundwater levels that are coming under the water coming out
the Himalayas.
So the Himalayas as you know sit right in the center of Asia and the yellow
river and the Yangtze River sort of feed China.
And you have the Helmand River feeds Afghanistan the Indus River feeds Pakistan
and the Ganges River feeds North China.
And you've got the Ganges goes into Bangladesh.
The problem the Petra of the Magna all feed Bangladesh area then you have the
Mekong and the slowing and the Irrawaddy which do Vietnam and Thailand and
Cambodia and Burma.
So all of these come out of the Himalayan Mountains in what's happening the
groundwater in these regions is going down two to four metres a year.
So that's six to 12 13 feet every year.
The water table goes down Venice is sinking for similar reasons that this much
smaller only nine inches in the whole century Bangkok is thinking 13 centimeters
a year.
Mexico City.
Down to I hope I have those slides here.
No.
Forget it.
Mexico City is sinking and in a drastic way and there's a sense of so prominent.
There's very good data from Mexico City so Mexico City put in a subway.
We have wonderful subway.
If you had a young lady with me when I was in the subway and such getting
squeezed you get groped in the Mexico City subway.
But they laid it flat.
But now with the with the ground the sucking out the water the ground is sinking
and it doesn't sink evenly.
So now that the subway is like this and some of it that was underground is now
aboveground because the ground is just sunken away from from the subway
the sewers and the water supply have exactly the same problem.
Oh
water pipe in Mexico City.
The city itself has sunk 30 feet from from when this was the subways really
originally put down water pipe that was like laying flat on the ground in 1934
is now 26 feet over everyone's head
in some suburbs are sinking about two feet.
Every year.
Because it's all it's uneven and I don't really know the answer to that it's
getting why doesn't everything sort of just sink evenly it just doesn't happen.
So a flat subway ends up like this
yeah I do.
I don't know how they arrange that Paul.
You think everything would sink.
Yes.
I don't know.
They may I don't know.
I just don't know the answer.
In Mexico City the water supply as more water is pumped.
Of course to the city the rate of pumping is facets of the city sinks faster and
there's the pipes eventually get twisted.
They rupture.
There's now 40000 repaired ruptures that they repair each year and many more
that they that they they are not even reported and they don't get around to
repairing them.
And apparently one third of the water in the system leaks out and a lot of the
city lies below the sewer lines now.
So the sewage doesn't leave the city anymore collects in pools and they have now
had to construct vast pumping stations to pump it out the sewage back out from
from these pools.
They have
they're building a whole new much deeper sewage system.
They're building a hundred twenty four miles of 80 foot sewers.
Okay.
That's enough.
I think you get
the message here.
When they have a few more minutes so I put in your reading and just something
that you may think well why did you put that in is how much is being paid for
caviar and fission and things like that.
And it is part of a longer piece that I'm not going to have time to talk about.
But there's a lot of fish in the sea but a lot of lot of people that want to eat
fish.
So fishing is one of those industries that's really just cleaning out the sea of
fish when there were small boats.
Things are OK.
The fish could regenerate but now Korea and East Germany and Japan have these
huge huge ships that have Miles their nets or miles and miles long and they just
suck everything out of the sea so the fish are disappearing.
And you'd think that economically that as the fish disappear.
And even when they can't reproduce themselves it would get the uneconomical to
catch the fish anymore.
But in actual fact what happens is that
in the fishing there's there's presumably good fish that people like to eat.
And what happens is as those get fished out you go down to the next level of
fish and if you go into restaurants while you see this every couple of years
there's some new fish on the menu that I've never heard of.
Have you had had that experience.
And that's because the fish that you eat 2 3 years ago are now gone because
they've been fished out.
So the quality of the fish goes down and down.
But that is people if people have money they still want to buy the better
quality fish.
And it turns out they will pay almost anything for this the better quality fish.
And so what happens is that instead of the economics working for you that as it
gets more expensive to catch fish you led off on the fish.
The price of the fish goes up.
So it's still worthwhile to catch those fish.
And what happens then that the because of that economics the pressure to catch
these fish to extinction keep keeps up there.
And some of the outrageous prices that I that I gave you.
That's the point of of that kind of stuff.
OK.
So what you should realize is that environmental destruction is essential.
Most of it is a lot of it is irreversible loss of species is irreversible.
And if you want to wait a hundred million years yes some species will
differentiate you'll get new species but that's basically reversible so things
like fishing out various species in the sea so that they don't recover is an
irreversible kind of thing loss of habitat is generally irreversible.
Then I think I described you northeast of Brazil where or all of Brazil of any
jungle region where the whole ecosystem is kept going by the matter of fungi
that recycle the nutrients in in the jungle.
When you cut down the trees the sun beats down kills the fungi you no longer
have this map of fungi.
So now something falls into it.
It doesn't get decomposed the nutrients don't go back into the trees and the
whole land dries out and becomes what they call ladder right which is hard soil
hard like like rock soil and it's not clear that that ever ever can recover fish
stocks.
They the cod stocks decline like 20 30 years ago and they really have not come
back even though they've really cut down the fishing and banned it mostly.
They're not they're not coming back.
This apparently too small of a population for the reproduction system
to work well
because this is irreversible because this is very important point because
environmental damage is irreversible as population increases as the world
economy increases the pressure on the environment gets worse and worse.
You can imagine a nice scenario where eventually population comes down and maybe
some of the pressure is let off.
But what you have to worry about is that peak because the things that are going
to disappear irreversibly your species your habitat your so forth depend not on
the level now but on the maximum demand that once the maximum once.
And if the maxim down comes off it's OK.
So what we have to worry about is this peak issue of population and other
demands on the environment.
And it's this peak issue that becomes important.
We've seen the great range of variability and the U.N.
projections we could reach a peak at a billion more people or 2 billion or 3 or
4 or 5 or 6 or 7 8 or 12 or so who knows how many more billions and which of
those curves happens is not gonna be a random event it depends on what humans do
right now.
And because of momentum the people that are born now are going to have children
and they're there they're a cumulative factor in the environment.
So whatever the birth rate now is whatever the population growth rate is now if
that eventually stops is the momentum for another 100 or 150 years and I showed
you the data from various countries showing that even after they reach
replacement level fertility their population grows for another 100 years or so
forth.
So again what we do now determines the maximum environmental destruction that's
that's going on.
And I think one of the most important points is that environmental solutions are
difficult.
It is not an easy job to fix the environment like global warming.
There's huge arguments whether we should try to prevent it or should we just try
to adapt it.
And I think half your course is in the forestry school.
Ah no it's better to let it happen and it's going to be cheaper to adapt to it.
And the other half of the courses thing it's a horrible thing.
We've got to try to prevent it and mostly like using solar power wind power the
costs of nuclear power even the costs are so very high that with current
technology the alternatives are not really not feasible.
So what's happening is China is building a new coal plant every week.
They're just they're not they would love to reduce their pollution they've done
whatever they can but they have their population still growing that huge poor
population.
They need the energy.
They have no choice now but to build power plants.
And what do you tell the Chinese to know your people should should keep being
poor don't build the coal power plants.
Well we don't say that and they're not going to do it anyway because their
people demand some decent standard of living which requires energy.
So look CO2 in the air goes crazy.
So if there are no easy fixes for the environment from from that kind of side
it's a really very hard job.
The only success that one can really claim in the last say 50 years for what you
might call the environmental movement is the population is on the population
front.
You've seen I've shown you many many times that in around the Third World store
up till 1950 1960 the birth rate was 6 7 8
people per children per woman.
And now it's dropped to below half that in fact about 2.8.
So it's something like less than a half of that often enormous progress in that
area.
I've shown you again in many different ways that people want fewer children than
every country every developing country of the world that you ask how many they
want you ask you find out how many they have that in every country the number
that they're having is above what they want and massive affects us like Bolivia
which is not one of your most advanced countries and universally around world 70
80 percent of the women want to not have children.
70 percent just totally don't want another 10 percent.
Well not in the next two years.
So the technology we have condoms are not wonderful.
Birth control pills are not wonderful.
It's not wonderful but it's it's good enough to do the job.
So population is is is the rare issue where a lot has been done and a lot can be
done.
We don't have to win the hearts and minds of the people they're ready telling us
they want fewer children than they're having.
We don't need new technology.
It's dirt cheap compared to the compared to like getting rid of carbon in the
atmosphere or reducing its but dirt cheap in a cycle of pills on the world
market is 80 cents a diaphragm is a buck and a quarter.
I mean we're talking dirt cheap and the medical knowledge to provide these
things is almost at the Barefoot Doctor level so you don't need very highly
trained personnel and as I mentioned to labor and even educated labor in their
developing countries is cheap.
So
so so of all the possible things one can do to improve the environmental
situation looks to me like encouraging the continued decline of fertility is is
the is the easiest thing.
You don't have to spend a lot of money.
Most of the people in the world will be.
Yeah.
Rah rah.
I want that.
And and we've seen from Ryerson lecture here that with a very little bit I mean
he puts on one soap opera you know which runs four to three times a week for
like a year which is significant but very small intervention and very cheap.
And the number of people going to family planning clinic doubles and triples and
in just incredible amount of progress with a very small input.
So this is very very doable thing.
And we have a long way to go.
The fertility as I've said has come down from six seven eight to two point six
as a global average but two point six is still a 30 percent increase every
generation.
So population growth under showed you is about a billion people every 13 years
now.
And it's still very high.
Bringing it down further is probably the only feasible reasonable realistic
thing that one can do to two massive I mean but the environment is going to hell
in such a massive rate.
We need some massive change.
And I don't think anything else comes close to what you can do with population.
I challenge environmentalists all the time and say look every 13 years is
another billion people add up all the environmental
environment all the conservation that environmentalists have ever done or the
restoration at that I compare that to a footprint of a billion people in 13
years.
It's not in the same year just not in the same ballpark.
And yet that message doesn't doesn't get through.
There's a wonderful quote and this is maybe the cameras don't even want it that
the Peter Beard who's one of the most famous conservation writers in Africa and
he's very outspoken and does not use polite language all the time.
This is a quote from him.
I broke my ass to do these conscientious books he did all kinds of books on the
environment in Africa but the public is not getting it at all.
You showed them photographs of 30000 carcasses with the ivory tusks still in
place.
That's eleven thirty thousand ivory elephants and the tusks are still in place
and they tried to tell you that we should prosecute poachers as if that.
That was the issue.
Doesn't anyone realize that people are hungry and using these animals for food.
People still think it's wild Africa.
Doesn't anyone realize that this is all about population pressure.
What the new uses the F word what the f is going on out there in the
conservation world.
He capitalizes Connors as as as as for con job.
Nothing but lies fundraising lies and I think we are.
I mean he's overstates things and as you know that's one of my pedagogical tools
is to engage somewhat an overstatement.
You remember it though.
And so you know that the whole environmental movement has got its head in the
sand about the one thing that that could really probably make a big difference.
So just to conclude Nike that the Earth is in a big race.
You have shown your population is increasing environmental problems are
increasing but fertility is coming down depending on how these two
countervailing forces work in the future we will either come to a smooth landing
a soft landing that fertility will come down fast enough that takes the pressure
off the increasing environmental issues or it won't or if population won't come
down fast enough and then we're off into who knows what.
So that's I think that what to take away from this course the tremendous race
between the increase of population billion people will every 13 years the
decline in fertility decline since 1960 and about 40 50 years and climbed to
more than half.
How is that race going to be won and what do we conclude.
Which side is going to win that race and what can we politically what can we do
about it.
OK.
Have a good summer.
Have a good chat.
About.